[Music]
on a gray drizzly spring day bright
color and the strains of God Save the
King signaled the start of a short
Journey decades in the making it was
fully 70 years ago on another rainy day
in 1953 that London last Saw such scenes
that day Charles's mother was crowned
Queen Elizabeth II
for all the close planning and
rehearsing an apparent unscheduled pause
before Queen consort and King processed
into a place where their predecessors
had been crowned for a thousand years
behind Charles his grandson Prince
George a young boy with a close-up look
at a ceremony he too is expected to
experience
Majesty as children of the kingdom of
God we
in his name and after his example I come
not to be served but to serve
throughout this Christian service there
was ancient and modern a promise to
secure Protestant succession to the
throne while also a recognition of
today's multi-faith Britain
the church established by law whose
settlement you will swear to maintain
will seek to Foster an environment in
which peoples of all faiths and beliefs
may live freely
and on the congregation of 2000 there
were heads of state members of royal
families and also 400 community and
charity workers recognized for their
service it was reminder too of family
dramas of recent years Prince Harry
attending seated well behind his brother
William and without his wife Megan
to music written by Handel for the
coronation of George II in the 18th
century came the moment described as a
personal one between King and God
King Charles Anointed with oil on his
head hands and breast screened from the
congregation and the cameras
then just after midday Seated on the
coronation chair and underneath it the
stone on which Scottish Kings had been
crowned for hundreds of years Charles
III received his crown God saved the
king
a moment marked across London across the
country with gun salutes
moments later the familial and the
ceremonial coincided hi William Prince
of Wales pledge my loyalty to you son
and Heir voicing an oath to father and
King
foreign
king and queen emerged to a celebratory
ringing of the Abbey's Bells through the
centuries coronations have preserved
Traditions but also been adapted to suit
the political and religious priorities
of the Monarch and of the time and this
one is no different from the words
spoken in the Abbey to the procession
back to Buckingham Palace
for all the Pomp and Military display of
this 4 000 strong parade this was a
shortened slimmed down journey in
comparison to that of Charles's mother
70 years ago the unspoken mission to
maintain support and relevance for a
monarchy at a time of transition and
changing public attitudes
one more reflection of Royal occasions
past as the family gathered on the
balcony and Britain's oldest ever newly
crowned Monarch marked the moment to
which he spent a long lifetime preparing
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera London